this sound
woke me up
sound like good
like a small animal being trapped as
some
never heard a man cry when I walked into
the kitchen is on my father all like
curry was the ashtray must have been
like a honey cigarettes in it ash like a
mountain mmm when he stopped crying he
just SAT there I think he didn't know
what else to do was he saw me he just
goes your mother left she's not coming
back just like that
the year before we lost our dog and I
want to make these posters so that you
don't want some of the call us if she
was lost like I think I found my dog but
today's day my father will sit there
tell you that he helped me make those
posters but he didn't he SAT there he's
right there and then I went out by
myself on school street asking people if
they see my mother her name was Doris
McRae by the way then I mother linen
tangerine Florida had a little
restaurant called Carl's still there and
you know I wanted to believe that that's
where she went but after a while it kind
of came to terms with the fact that if
she left she there for a reason then I
didn't want my mother anymore and she
wasn't coming back
and now you know about my family but uh
I said kind of true my apartment